[Music]
welcome to bananamores i'm so excited to
watch this next performer light up
the bananamore stage get ready for
comedy greatness
thank you mitzi i'm percy rostamji and i
want to know how y'all doing
are you guys ready for an indian queer
so look quarantine sucks
okay everything's closed the only thing
opening up slowly are relationships all
right
and if you guys think that you've had a
dry spell
i have been single in celibate for seven
years
you guys like books welcome to
charlotte's web
so i was like i'm going on a date i'm
doing it this is this is my year i'm
going to do it this will be all said
right this is
i'm going on my first date i'm
vaccinated it's going to be great so i
saw this guy
at a crosswalk and he looks really cute
and so i walked up onto him
and i noticed he was scary as heck so i
walked on back there's a jazz walk i was
like
nope not not not the one i mean like you
know ripping muscles and giant biceps
and veins popping out of his eye
okay so i was like don't mess with that
but
on his right bicep in giant tattooed
letters
was the word dancer
i was like oh never judge a book by its
cover unless it's charlotte's web
um i literally turned him by his bicep i
was like you're a dancer
i'm a dancer are you classically trained
i actually toured with janet it was
janet reno but still
uh a little dancer humor which he did
not understand and did not like
uh i looked closer because he was not
reciprocating anything back to me
and his tattoo actually said danger
okay not dancer those are two very
different things
my dangerous dancer so i jazz walked
right out of that situation
and onto a tinder tinder
uh where i met this great guy and he was
lovely and
the conversation was popping and flowing
because that's very important and he was
from the enchanting land of ecuador
this amazing beautiful place uh it's in
south america did not know that
neighbors
uh and he had his beautiful accent but
he was only in town
for one more night so we just had to
meet so our first date was just
me and him and his entire ecuadorian
family
at his godmother's 90th birthday party
dinner on the patio okay safety
and by on the patio i mean the
restaurant through uh some tarp and some
chairs into the street because that's
what they'd be doing now
they're like it's the safest new way to
eat in the middle of the street
you won't get hit by covered but just by
a bus um and so mid dinner you know
we're enjoying ourselves
uh he's like percy uh i want to
introduce you
it's time attention a tension this is a
fork
uh mama papa dia prima cabras everybody
come on let's see listen
this is my new friend percy and i'm gay
i was mid-wave i was like i got
and i'm gay this is the moment
his entire ecuadorian family looking at
him with adoration and stars in their
eyes my beautiful pure sun
and they pivoted and looked at me like
you did this to our baby
i'm not trying to get beat up i was like
ew you're what
that is disgusting what a hard life
grandma
we don't like it we don't like it right
but we don't like it we don't like it
they weren't buying any of that so
that is the story of how i got chased
out of the cheesecake fact
how i jazz rant out of a cheesecake
factory in beverly hills
i'm still single thank you mitzi thank
you everybody i'm personally stomgy
in case you know anybody send him my way
please he's so lonely
i literally did not stop laughing the
whole time
can someone pass me my inhaler i can't
even contain my excitement for this next
comedian
all you people watching at home get
those hands of clapping
thank you thank you mitzi yes oh man
just happy i made it today because i'm
just so
hungover you know
sorry i mean i'm i'm pregnant i
uh i often get those two mixed up
because
you know when you find out for both you
you just start throwing up
uh a bunch and then you swear off
alcohol for some time
and then you're always just like i'm
never doing that again
like never this is our second
um coming at you and i have one who
he's is a toddler and you know it's it's
quarantine
it's been a trip but one thing that i've
learned
from this is it's beautiful to be around
children because you learn so much about
them and about yourself
and um the other day we were playing
peek-a-boo
which is his favorite game and uh we
were in the living room
we were by the uh the coffee table and
he was going down
and then he'd come up and i'd be like
right he's delighted
and then he would go back down and he
would come back up and i was like oh my
god you were still a baby
and he was delighted and then one time
he just
he went down and stayed
down and uh i just heard him going
and i was like oh my gosh are you okay
are you okay and i looked over the edge
and he looked up at me and he was just
like
and then stood back up like it's your
turn mom and i realized
um he was pooping
like just mid his turn
in the game just squatted down and took
a deuce
and i was like i want
that confidence it's amazing that
feeling
and i think there's something special
about it especially being a woman
because society dictates that women
you know we shouldn't perspire we
shouldn't fart
we shouldn't poop like just don't don't
let your bodies work
ladies okay it's horrible like i don't
know what men
do in public washrooms because i've
never been in them but i assume it's
like cross swords and talk sports i
don't know
but i'll tell you how it works in a
women's washroom
okay you walk into a woman's washroom
completely
dead silent like there's like
tumbleweeds
rolling past and not because there's no
women in there oh
every stall is full okay but it's
because every woman in there
is waiting for everyone else to leave so
that she can do her business
oh and we have the patience of saints do
we not ladies
like i've missed flights i've missed job
interviews because i'm like i'ma wait
everybody out
thank you guys so much for having me at
bananamores uh it's an absolute pleasure
back to you mitzi i can't even get over
how much talent this person has the
banana more stage is
lucky to have that one i'll tell ya if
you don't know this next comedian yet
you're about to have your mind blown
give it up for one of my favorites sam
taggart
wow hello um it is uh
simply incredible to be at banana morris
today i'm thrilled
um you know it is kind of a weird time
to be like
um recording this because um
currently to the day it is uh the one
year anniversary of lockdown
um and you know it kind of begs for
reflection
and normally you know i i don't really
like to self-reflect i
i think it's kind of problematic because
what if i see my own flaws
no thank you um but it's a special
occasion so
when in rome um so a year ago
today i was actually doing something
kind of exciting
i was um emily in paris which is what i
call working temporarily in a foreign
country
and rudely and almost on purposely not
using the language at all
um you know it wasn't exactly paris um
i was in uh the paris of south america
which is santiago chile
um and at this point cobid was like
you know it's in the news you're hearing
about it but it kind of feels like
well that's not for me like it's kind of
like cavities where it's like
yeah other people get those because
they're like not good people like i'm
really really nice so i'm not gonna get
that
but thank you so i'm in chile for work
and i'm you know during the days oh i'm
working so hard i'm working with an
incredible team of people
it's hello it's great job it's awesome
work
we're working and then you know at night
well i'm in a foreign country so it's
let's go to a restaurant let's go to a
bar let's go to a discoteca
why not i'm again you know i'm living it
up
and honestly it was lovely or as emily
and paris would say
it was lovely she never learned the
language she only speaks english even
like a full
season in it's kind of crazy but anyway
about four days into this um lovely
journey
i get the call that almost every
writer performer actor begs for it is
the call from the hr department of a
giant media conglomerate
and i pick up the phone and i'm like
yes this is he and they're like
um yeah hi um this is regarding your
recent audition
and i'm like this is gigantic i'm about
to blow up i'm about to pop all the way
off
and they're like yeah so the person
running that audition um actually did
have kovid
so you have been exposed
yeah so have a good day and i tried to
ask a question
and she quickly got off the phone
presumably to tell 25
other men who look and sound almost
exactly like me but some slightly hotter
and some slightly less hot that they
were also exposed
so i'm in my hotel room and i'm just
like freaking out because it's like wait
i could have
this thing i could have covid and that's
like wait if i can have covid that means
i can get like
cavities too like this is so messed up
like my entire world view is crumbling
and then like i can't even think about
the cavities because i'm realizing like
oh my god
everyone that i've interacted with if i
have it
has also been exposed and i'm like
running through each delightful little
person i've met
and it's like even if we're just
counting the elderly
it's like way more people than you would
expect and so
i'm fully freaking out and i'm like okay
it's not a huge deal it's not a huge
deal like
maybe if you just like maybe it's
already rampant in chile
in this situation that would be a good
thing because you know i wouldn't be
making a huge splash
so i look up how many people in chile
currently have kovid
and at that point it was 10. 10 people
had it
and so now i'm like okay not only do i
have it
potentially but i've maybe doubled or
tripled the amount of people that have
been exposed in the entire nation of
chile
that's bad like i'm gonna be like the
face of evil for generations to come
i'm gonna be in like kids stories about
like evil people
it's insane i'm gonna be like what the
zebra muscle is to the great lakes
region or
what dr phil is to oprah's legacy or i
don't know what emily is to parisians
who hate american tourists
i'm freaking out i'm freaking out i'm
freaking out eventually
i managed to get a test because well i
know people
yeah i can get a test if i want to get
over it and
it comes back negative all good
i'm totally fine i breathe a sigh of
relief
and then i just safely go back to new
york and
spend basically the rest of the year in
my apartment
but you know i've got a feeling that
just like emily and paris season two
i'll be coming out soon too and even
though everyone's like no we're good
you don't really want you can stay i'll
be coming out soon people may be like no
no thank you but i'll be coming out you
lord no no i'm good you can stay in your
apartment
but i'm coming out soon it's always
emily in paris too thank you so much
i've been sam
doesn't get any better than this guy i
literally did not stop
laughing the whole time sam performed